[Music]
so yes we begin with that breaking news
from the occupied West Bank Israeli
media I've reported at least one woman
has been killed and another wounded in a
shooting attack that happened near the
city of Hebron
Israeli media say at least one or
several Palestinian suspects opened fire
from a passing vehicle
for more on this Harry forces joining us
live from West Jerusalem uh speaking to
us over the phone so Harry just tell us
what more do we know at this point
well yeah the details coming in so far
are relatively scant but we do know that
this woman in her mid-40s an Israeli has
been confirmed dead at the scene after
uh emergency crews tried first to give
her
assistance at the roadside a male also
in his 40s was taken to a medical center
uh they were in their car according to
reports driving along Route 60 which is
one of the main routes through the
occupied West Bank South of the southern
city of headron uh when they came under
Fire according to Israeli reports uh
military personnel have been dispatched
and are hunting while the Israeli media
say are Futures plural but we don't have
confirmation yet of exactly how many
people may have been involved in this
attack also reports coming from local
Israeli settlement and his colleague was
ready settlement in the area saying that
entry and exits from that settlement had
been closed as part of this military
operation uh it's the latest such attack
on Saturday there was another attack so
the North in the occupied West Bank
were two Israelis from Southern Israel
who were inside the West Bank at a car
repair center they were shot dead uh at
that place a father and son UH 60 year
old and a son in his late 20s uh all of
this of course coming in the context of
increasing violence throughout the
course of 2023 especially in the
occupied West Bank where more than 180
Palestinians have been killed and now uh
more than 30 Israelis so far this year
as well
all right Harry will you be there for
the moment thanks very much indeed for
that update Harry Force reporting on
Israeli media reports of a woman being
killed during a shooting in the occupied
West Bank thanks Harry